IS.
>> KILLINGS ARE UP 50% FROM
BEFORE COVID.
WHERE IS THIS COMING FROM.
>> REMEMBER, IN GEORGIA WE WERE
OPEN UP BEFORE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, SO OUR NIGHT CLUBS AND
OUR BARS REMAINED OPEN.
WE HAD PEOPLE TRAVELING HERE
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO PARTY
IN OUR CITY.
WE BELIEVE THAT GIVING AT LEAST
1,000 YOUNG PEOPLE TO WORK THIS
SUMMER WILL HELP.
THERE IS STILL SO MUCH WORK TO
BE DONE.
AND UNTIL WE DEAL WITH THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN THIS COUNTRY, HOW EASILY
YOUNG PEOPLE, PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES CAN ACCESS GUNS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AINSLEY: THAT’S ATLANTA’S MAYOR
POINTING BLAME FOR HER CITY’S
CRIME RATE.
OUR NEXT GUEST FIRING BACK
CALLING OUT THE LEFT’S ANTI-SOFT
ON CRIME AGENDA.
STEVE: GEORGIA GOVERNOR BRIAN
KEMP JOINS US WITH MORE.
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
STEVE: SHE IS BLAMING EVERYBODY
EXCEPT HER POLICIES.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT WELL, WE
WERE, THANKS TO YOUR POLICIES,
GEORGIA REOPENED BEFORE A LOT OF
OTHER PLACES.
AND SHE IS SAYING THAT’S WHY
THERE IS SUCH A SURGE IN CRIME.
BUT YOU LOOK TO THE STATE TO THE
SOUTH OF YOU FLORIDA, I DON’T
SEE SIMILAR NUMBERS THERE.
>> LOOK, COLORADO, OKLAHOMA,
THERE WERE PLENTY OF OTHER
STATES.
SOUTH DAKOTA WAS OPEN.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
LEADERS BLAMING SOMEBODY ELSE
FOR PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR OWN JURISDICTION, QUITE
HONESTLY, I KNOW I’M FED UP WITH
IT.
FOR TWO MONTHS WE ARE HAD A
CRIME SUPPRESSION UNIT WORKING
USING EXTRA STATE RESOURCES,
EMERGENCY FUNDING, TO TRY TO
HELP WITH THE PROBLEM BECAUSE I
HEAR ABOUT IT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND IN JUST TWO MONTHS, BY
PUTTING BOOTS ON THE GROUND,
OFFICERS ON THE STREET, AND IN
THE AIR, AND WORKING WITH STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS, WE HAVE
DONE ALMOST 3100S ARRESTS.
WE VERY APPREHENDED 71 PEOPLE
WHO HAD OUTSTANDING WARRANTS AND
WE HAVE IMPOUNDED ALMOST 300
VEHICLES GOING AFTER STREET
CRIMES.
AND WE’RE NOT BLAMING THAT ON
ANYBODY ELSE.
WE’RE JUST DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
IT AND IT’S TIME THAT SHE DID AS
WELL.
AINSLEY: IF YOU LOOK AT BUCK
HEAD, MURDERS UP ALMOST 50%,
WHICH IS THAT NEIGHBORHOOD IN
DOWNTOWN ATLANTA.
ROBBERY, AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS UP
40%.
CAR THEFT UP 65%.
LENNOX SQUARE MALL GUNFIRE AT
THE CHEESE CAKE FACTORY.
MACY EMPLOYEES SHOT.
GUN BATTLE OUTSIDE OF
BLOOMINGDALE’S.
IN APRIL A 60-YEAR-OLD COME
SEVERELY BEATEN IN THE PARKING
LOT AND THEY TOOK HER PURSE.
TWO WEEKS AGO GO 15-YEAR-OLDS
SHOT AND ALMOST KILLED A
SECURITY GUARD AT THE APPLE
STORE.
WHAT’S THE REAL REASON FOR ALL
THIS CRIME?
>> LOOK, PEOPLE SHOULDN’T BE
SCARED BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY WANT
TO GET GAS IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
WE FOCUS ON BUCK HEAD THIS
WEEKEND.
WE STAYED OUT LATE, YOU KNOW,
THE BARS HAVE BEEN -- OR AT
LEAST SOME BARS HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH A LOT OF THESE
GATHERINGS OF A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE WERE POLICING THOSE WHEN THEY
CLOSED THIS WEEKEND.
AND IT WAS VERY EFFECTIVE
TACTIC.
IN FACT, ATLANTA POLICE
DEPARTMENT WAS THANKING US FOR
THEIR PARTNERSHIP OVER THE
WEEKEND.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE GOT TO START
TACKLING THE PROBLEM WHERE IT
HAPPENS.
THEY KNOW WHERE IT IS.
THEY NEED SOMEONE TO BACK THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY UP, BACK
THE MEN AND WOMEN ON THE STREET
UP.
AND GIVE THEM DIRECTION TO GO
AFTER THESE FOLKS AND SEND A
MESSAGE.
THAT’S WHAT I HAVE TOLD OUR
FOLKS.
WE HAVE GOT A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE ATLANTA POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT THEY ARE HAVING TO RIDE WITH
US BECAUSE THEY CAN’T CHASE
ANYBODY.
IT’S HARD TO GO AFTER VIOLENT
CRIMINALS WHEN THEY RUN AWAY
FROM YOU AND YOU CAN’T CHASE
THEM.
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO BE VERY
SMART ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THERE IS A LOT
OF REASONS THAT YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE THIS HAPPENING.
BUT THE FACT IS THERE IS ONE WAY
TO STOP IT.
AND THAT’S TO GO AFTER THEM AND
SEND A MESSAGE AND SAY, LOOK, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH
THIS ANYMORE.
YOU KNOW, THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM IN
FULTON COUNTY IS A SOURCE OF
PROBLEM WITH THIS AS WELL WITH
THE REVOLVING DOOR OF THESE
CAREER CRIMINALS CONTINUING TO
GET OUT OF JAIL THE NEXT DAY.
AND WE’RE CHASING THEM AGAIN.
BRIAN: YEAH, I MEAN, THE NUMBERS
ARE STUNNING.
WE WENT OVER IN THE FIRST HOUR
IN CASE YOU MISSED IT ATLANTA
HOMICIDES UP 58%.
SHOOTINGS UP.
SHOOTINGS UP 64%.
THE MOST EGREGIOUS PORTLAND WE
HAVE BEEN WATCHING IT UP 533%
WITH SHOOTINGS UP 126%.
IT’S VERY CONSISTENT.
IT’S A VERY PERMISSIVE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
MAYOR WHO BLAMES THE COPS FIRST
AND CRIME IS JUST A SYMPTOM OF
BAD POLICING.
NO ONE IS BUYING IT.
IT’S NOT MAKING THE AVERAGE
PERSON SAFE.
AND I JUST WON CONSERVATORSHIP
WHEN THE BACKLASH WILL BEGIN.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
ELECTIONS.
OBVIOUSLY THE FORMER PRESIDENT
IS VERY CRITICAL OF YOU GUYS.
FOR WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE
ELECTION.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS STILL A
CONFLICT THERE.
BUT ONE THING THAT HAPPENED OVER
THE WEEKEND IS THAT GOING
THROUGH THE VOTER ROLES, BETWEEN
UNRESPONSIVE PEOPLE, PEOPLE
MOVING, UNABLE TO VALIDATE IDS,
REMOVED 100,000 OUTDATED NAMES
FROM YOUR VOTER ROLES.
PEOPLE -- VOTERROLLS.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT OUTDATED
REACTION.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THAT.
>> LET ME TALK ABOUT THE LAST
TOPIC.
THE NEW FULTON COUNTY SHERIFF
ARE SUPPORTIVE AFTER GOING AFTER
VIOLENT CRIMES.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT POINT.
US MAKING SURE THE VOTER ROLLS
ARE UPDATED AND SECURE.
LIST MAINTENANCE, WE ARE
FOLLOWING FEDERAL LAW IN THIS
STATE.
DID I THAT NINE YEARS WHEN I WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE LEFT WAS OUTRAGED AS WELL.
THEY ACT LIKE NOBODY EVER MOVES
OUT OF THE STATE AND DOESN’T
NOTIFY THE SECRETARY OF STATE’S
OFFICE THAT THEY ARE MOVING.
SO I THINK IT’S PERTINENT FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE’S OFFICE
TO BE FOLLOWING FEDERAL LAW WHEN
IT COMES TO LIST MAINTENANCE AND
UPDATED.
YOU NEED TO REMOVE DESEIZE
SEIZED PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY IN GEORGIA BUT
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IT’S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THESE
HOLLOW TALKING POINTS OF THE
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE REALLY BEING
HYPOCRITICAL IF YOU THINK
ABOUTING VOTING LAW 2.0, YOU
KNOW, MONTH AND A HALF AGO, AND
NOW SHE IS SAYING THINGS LIKE 15
DAYS OF EARLY VOTING AND VOTER
IDENTIFICATION WHEN YOU VOTE ARE
PERFECTLY FINE WHEN IT’S JOE
MANCHIN’S BILLS AND IT’S A
COMPROMISE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THEY CAN’T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
IN GEORGIA IT’S EASY TO VOTE AND
HARD TO CHEAT.
STEVE: THERE YOU GO.
NEW YORK IS JUST WRAPPING UP
EARLY VOTING HERE.
I THINK THEY IT 20 DAYS TWICE AS
MANY IN GEORGIA.
GOVERNOR, REAL QUICK, I DON’T
KNOW HOW MUCH TIME YOU SPEND ON
TWITTER, HERSCHEL WALKER, THE
LEGENDARY FOOTBALL PLAYER, PUT
THIS OUT AND WE WANT YOU TO KIND
OF FIGURE OUT WHAT HE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
LOOK HERE.
HEY, WHAT YOU HEAR THERE IS
HULK.
THAT’S WHAT I CALL, YOU KNOW,
HE’S READY I’M GETTING READY AND
WE CAN RUN WITH THE BIG DOGS.
STEVE: SO EITHER HE IS GOING TO
OPEN A CAR DEALERSHIP OR IS HE
GOING TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, ONE THING ABOUT HERBAL,
HEHERSCHEL.
IS HE A DAMN GOOD DOG.
GOOD AMERICAN.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT HE IS GOING
TO DO.
HE KEEPS I PEOPLE THINKING.
I AM SURE PEOPLE SAW THAT AND
WONDERING WHAT HE IS GOING TO
DO.
ONE THING ABOUT HERSCHEL, IS HE
INDEPENDENT PERSON HE WILL DO
WHAT HE FEELS IS RIGHT IN HIS
HEART AND HIS MIND.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BRIAN: DO YOU WANT HIM TO RUN?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK HE BRINGS
A LOT TO THE TABLE.
YOU KNOW, RUNNING STATEWIDE IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT IS VERY TOUGH
AS YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE GOT HAVE IT IN YOUR
HEART.
YOU HAVE GOT TO HAVE IT IN YOUR
GUT.
THAT’S A DECISION THAT HE WILL
HAVE TO MAKE.
AINSLEY: HE IS SO LOVED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY BUT
ESPECIALLY IN YOUR STATE.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO DO IT.